if life begins at forty then let rival
car makers be where the BMW 3 series has
been continually evolving over six
generations
you know three series are very much of
the core of our brand and you know it
started back in the mid-70s it started
the longest success period and I think
automotive history some 14 million 3
Series have been sold around the world
since that point and of course today
comes in in many derivatives as well so
its core in the United States its core
in in Asia and it's also cool here in
Europe so we're delighted with this
positioning and what better place to
unveil the latest sedan and touring
sports wagon versions than the BMW
museum in Munich it's home to various
historical models including the
beginnings of the 3-series the enduring
success story began back in 1975 BMW
launched a car that would have a
defining influence on generations of
drivers a compact mid-range model with
both executive and sporting ambitions
and with exterior and interior styling
that was truly innovative a driver
oriented front cabin would be a
characteristic feature of BMWs new baby
the 3-series would also soon leave its
mark on the track 2 at home in Germany
and on the international racing circuit
maybe was not the one of the best was of
the best car for tooling car and with it
car we could achieve many titles we won
immediately 1987 we want the war to link
our championship and 98 that we want a
European and then in 80 89 every bombed
a DTM so was a fantastic beautiful place
in with it with its car and the
engineers have given a 3-series a nice
makeover in time for its big birthday of
course the interior has seen a series of
changes over the last four decades
upgraded materials plus electronic
assists and other features that leave
nothing to be desired what has remained
is the driver friendly front cabin then
there's the one edition of the three
series that was originally not really
part of BMWs plans but is today an
integral part of the legend the turing
sports wagon
just one the other video Gangnam it came
about due to max rice Burks family
vacations whenever he wanted to take his
wife and children on vacation there was
the problem of packing in all the
luggage in the regular 3-series
notchback he was both a BMW engineer and
a keen BMW driver being so in april
nineteen eighty-four he began thinking
about how to build a wagon version call
me decided to shift back the c-pillar
and extend the roof he could already
picture it remaining hopeful for many
the 3-series was and is more than just a
means of transportation it's a way of
life the 3-series was soon in big demand
among collectors Daniel Falcon bag is
the owner of one of the most
comprehensive collections of the
3-series de fust en su the model exerts
an amazing attraction he explains
because it's such a versatile car
compared with many others it's agile
responsive and has a really wide range
of uses he just loves it ain't that spy
on polk i Samantha
that takes a closer look to detect new
changes on the exterior at the front the
trademark kidney grill has gotten wider
and the lights have been modernized
front and back in both the sedan and
wagon versions
the changes under the hood are more
obvious the top of the range engine is a
3 liter 6 cylinder unit in the BMW 340 I
it delivers 240 kilowatts of power and
acceleration from 0 to 100 km/h and 5.2
seconds top speed is an electronically
limited 250 km/h official fuel
consumption is a 7.7 liters of premium
unleaded for 100 kilometers not bad a
first for the 3 series is a 1.5 liter
three-cylinder engine in the 318i BMW
claims a fuel economy of just five
liters for 100 kilometers but still with
a peak speed of 210 km/h a plug-in
hybrid edition is slated for launch in
2016
you